technology companies encourage their
employees to work together because
studies show the teams tend to innovate
faster achieve higher productivity see
mistakes more quickly and find better
solutions to problems yet not every team
is successful so how do you build a
highly effective team that is capable of
delivering expected results
a study run by Google will shed some
light on this question and help us
identify trades that all successful
Google teams shared several years ago
who will launch an internal project
Aristotle which was a huge data study
focused on the teamwork the tech giant
spent millions of dollars tracking 180
separate teams for three years the goal
of the project was simple yet ambitious
to find out what are the traits of the
highest performing teams in other words
the company wanted to know why some
teams stumbled while others sort
initially the researchers hypothesis was
that maybe best teams had members who
liked each other a lot or there was a
healthy mix of personality types while
the team members were friends outside of
work
yet none of these seemed to matter
the researchers could not find any
meaningful patterns in the data
basically there was no evidence that a
mix of specific personality types or
skills or backgrounds
made any difference the whole part of
the equation didn't seem to matter as
the researchers continued to study the
group's
they noticed two behaviors that all of
the best teams shared first is that the
team members spoke in roughly the same
proportion a phenomenon the researchers
call inequality in distribution of
conversational turn-taking
on some teams everyone spoke during each
task while on others leadership shifted
among teammates from assignment to
assignment but in each case at the end
of the day everyone had spoken roughly
the same amount in other words as long
as everyone got a chance to talk the
team did well but if only one person or
a small group spoke all the time the
collective intelligence declined second
the good teams all had high average
social sensitivity a fancy way of saying
they were skilled at reading how others
felt based on their tone of voice their
expressions in other nonverbal cues one
of the easiest way to determine social
sensitivity is to show someone photos of
a person's eyes and ask to describe what
that person is feeling an exam known as
reading the mind in the eyes people on
successful teams scored about average on
this test they seemed to know when
someone was feeling upset or left out
people on less effective teams in
contrast scored below average they
seemed to be less sensitive towards
their colleagues by the end of the
project researchers came to conclusion
that it didn't matter who was on the
team what mattered was how team members
treated each other
teams were everybody talked and
everybody showed respect by listening
and paying attention created
psychologically safe atmosphere inside
the team and psychological safety of
each member in the group had a positive
effect on the team's ability to succeed